hey little guys my name is trying to
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we took a look at github pull
requests and there's some of those in
make sure that you check out that video
if you haven't already today we're gonna
finally get to something that I've been
wanting to do for a really long time
just for my own sanity really and that
is polling input right so we set up this
whole event system which is great
because you're having an event system
receiving events whenever we press a key
or move the mouse or like the window
resizes that's all fantastic and that's
gonna form the basis for a lot of what
we actually build in hazal but there is
still the other side of input that is
important and that is polling input so
that's basically what I want instead of
me being notified when something happens
it's me being able to do at any point at
any point in our program ask hey is this
Kay down is this mouse button down you
know am i holding the Alt key as I move
my mouse because if we do that then
something else might one we might want
to change what that mouse move does
based on if that's held down right for
example it's a way in wave menteng a
camera control all right and we want
like a Maya style camera where we hold
down alt and then like you know the
middle mouse button a left mouse button
to rotate you know and then we move the
mouse I want to check the old keys down
I want to check if the left mouse button
is down and then if so when I move the
mouse I might receive a mousemove event
and on that Mouse move event if the alt
and the left mouse button are down then
I want to rotate the camera right stuff
like that we want to be able to actually
ask hazel if something is down now
obviously this could all be implemented
client-side from this event system that
we've built it's very easy for us to
simply be like okay well fine in my lair
every time I get a mouse press to ban
I'll just set the left mouse button to
be pressed and then the mouse release
tab and set it to false and that way I
can check well yes you can but obviously
that's a bit of a hassle having to do
that for like everything and build your
own system why build your own system to
do that if that's something that hazel
can actually provide so that's what
we're gonna do today when you take a
look at input we're gonna make a class
called input
like windows input because it's probably
be platform dependent at least I mean
the whole platform dependency King is a
little bit shady right now because we
are using gel of W which theoretically
means that all desktop platforms will
use gel W but I still as I mentioned and
what I do with the windows window klass
right I am splitting everything up per
platform the reason I'm doing that is
because in the future we might want to
move away from Jeff W and we might want
to use something else on Linux or Mac
versus Windows and so because of that
that'll be a huge refactor I don't want
to do that I still want to keep all the
platforms separate in case there's maybe
something in those files that we end up
making only for that platform so that's
the reason for that let's jump in let's
implement this input class okay so the
first thing I'm going to start off by
doing is over here in hazel I'm going to
come over into source will explain
platform and hazel and then just over
here in hazel making sure that I've got
show all files showing so that I'm not
like creating stuff in filters I'm gonna
add a new item we're gonna call it input
on H and that's really all it's going to
be we're just gonna have a header file
that is our input this is very similar
to what we had for the window header
file but we just had a just this this
window header file
right and then from there it was just
really an interface and then from there
we had an implementation where we had
windows window we're gonna kind of
follow that same convention here we're
gonna implement everything inside
windows window and then this will just
kind of be just that right but there's a
bit of a difference because with window
everything here they're just methods
whereas with input input is going to be
static in the sense that there's going
to be one global input kind of manager
and that's it whereas you can have
potentially several windows so several
things like that input I don't want to
be I don't want that to be per window or
anything like that it's going to be
global now technically speaking you will
probably have the like the separate
windows thing is interesting because
again I didn't want to make window
completely static it is right now though
because if you look at application and I
put
static you have one application per
hazel that obviously has a single window
so right now you can only have one
window so whether or not window is
static doesn't matter at this point but
input for now at least will be static
there are many ways that we could deal
with that and they're kind of
interesting complications to that
because on one hand if you have multiple
windows then maybe you want to pull
input from a particular window on the
other hand if it's static you can still
do that you could just say that if you
ask the input class if the mouse button
is pressed it will be after the
currently active window because
obviously you can only have one window
active at once anyway you can't have two
windows focused at the same time on your
computer so yeah there's a lot of things
to consider I'm not gonna kind of spend
too long kind of going through all of
them I don't think that's necessary but
anyway we're just gonna begin with the
input class and see where that takes us
so hazel API input I'm going to include
I never know what it's cold anymore I
think it's called something else in my
reporting tree but hazel core dot H to
get that hazel API thing and then we're
just gonna have essentially just a bunch
of static functions serve is keep rest
it's kind of probably one of the most
important ones we're just gonna take in
a key card now right now this will end
up being a GLW key card just because we
don't have key codes we need to make our
own key codes I've been stressing that
for alot we might do that next episode
but we need to have our own key codes
because we can't tie ourselves to gel if
W because of course that's going to end
up being potentially different on other
platforms as well as obviously like
that's not gonna be a thing on like
Android or other kind of devices once we
kind of get into that space as well now
here's the thing this is static however
what I'm going to do is I'm actually
going to make this as singleton so we're
gonna have a single instance of this
input class like that and then what
we're going what we're going to end up
doing is returning s instance and then
probably the implementation of this
function now this is where it gets
interesting because whilst that is a
thing what we're actually gonna end up
doing is having protected virtual
functions
so essentially this is keypress we're
gonna have a virtual version of that
which is um not static we're going to
call it is key pressed impulse sensor
implementation and then that's going to
take in a key code of course and that's
going to be pure virtual so this is what
we implement per platform in that actual
like a realization I guess of this
interface because this is just an
interface we do have like a variable but
it's static so it doesn't actually
belong to this class class has
absolutely no daughter in it this is
just a static global kind of s instances
does not belong to the class so that's
essentially how this whole thing is
gonna work and that's gonna call that
and then there you go okay so is key
pressed cause the implementation and
then that obviously is something that
will be kind of implemented by your
interface so just to kind of show you
show you an example before I add
everything else in platform windows I'm
going to make a new item and when we get
header file it's gonna be called windows
input dot H and then I'm also going to
make a CPP file with the same name so
windows input dot CPP I'm going to
include my precompiled header of course
every time you make new files by the way
especially CBP files you need to rerun
premi because as this stands I'm not
sure whether or not this will actually
be included in the program pilot headers
it may be you can see it is set to use
because that's the default for our
project so actually maybe you don't have
to rerun it I usually do anyway just for
sanity but it's not something you have
to do it so we'll include Windows input
and dot H and then what kind of
obviously just seven here I'm gonna copy
pierce whoops and put it in here we're
going to include hazel input and this
will be glass hazel API well actually I
don't probably don't want to actually
export this into the DLL file so we'll
probably just say
like we don't I don't think we want it
to be I mean we might yeah we probably
won't have to we'll see how this works
there so and then this will kind of just
override that so protected this will
kind of just override our function so
our virtual bull is key pressed int key
code okay so that's the override from
input sorry this one obviously and then
we'll kind of just implement that and
then what this will actually do right is
actually called G of W and then do
everything that we need to kind of do
that so this will be tied to jelf W
which is fairly fine because it's inside
windows it's inside our
platform-specific CPP file so it's not
gonna get compiled or in it anywhere
where W might not be available what
we're gonna do is we're gonna actually
get the window from the application and
then we actually need to get did you'll
have W window so this is interesting
because we do have an implementation for
this I think but it might need to be
changed because here's the thing right
at the moment if you take a look at our
window it's quite interesting actually
I'm kind of glad that we're getting into
this because it opens up a lot so at the
moment we have no way to access this
right we have a jail of W window however
we can't access that at the moment now
there's several things we could do we
could make this public there'll be
probably the worst thing you could do we
could make windows input a friend of
windows window that would make sense
because input window kind of tied
together could do that but because I
want to kind of make this API somewhat
powerful and potentially to people even
in the client side who might want to for
some reason do something that hazel
doesn't do I actually want to function a
public function in the API which exposes
JFW window now I obviously want this to
be somewhat portable and like I don't
want this to be specific for windows
window or anything like that I
want to do too much of that so what
we're actually gonna end up doing is
inside a window we're actually going to
add something here which is essentially
going to be a virtual void pointer get
native window okay and what this will do
is we'll make that Const what this will
do is actually return our gfw window
though the reason it's a void pointer is
because of course this doesn't have to
be a djellaba window if we're using some
other windowing library like this could
potentially return like an H wind or
something that could be anything right
but in this case is returning just this
native window okay just just this kind
of gel W pointer in this case so we'll
copy this we'll go into Windows window
we'll paste this in we can make it
inline and I'll probably keep it a
special this is another question I get
quite often why do I keep virtual in
here right so I don't do it every way
you can see I really don't I do
sometimes I probably should do it more
often but for example in here I kept
this as virtual and people like well
hang on do is something going to like
extend this windows info class am I
gonna have a child of this class and
that's why I want this there the answer
is nor it doesn't matter the thing is
when you make something virtual over
here in the base class everything down
the hierarchy like everywhere down the
hierarchy this function will be virtual
so if I don't put virtual here doesn't
matter it's still a virtual function why
because it's obviously deriving from a
virtual function so this is meaningless
like just because you're inputted that
does not mean this is suddenly not
virtual okay so you might as well put it
there because that's kind of a reminder
of the fact that it is special it's kind
of like why we use override
although override actually will generate
compile errors if you like you know miss
clap something because you're not
actually overriding anything whereas
vegetable warrant but it's just a little
reminder that this is in fact a virtual
function again you might not need to
have that because you have override
there and that makes sense that
obviously it's overriding a virtual
function but usually like most people
decide to actually leave this in here
because it is in fact a virtual function
so why not have just that extra
readability in your code to kind
just you know let you know that it is a
virtual function so that's why I do that
okay because it doesn't it doesn't make
a difference whether you happen or not
okay so um so there's now get native
winter and this is just furniture to
return our M window which is our gfw
window fantastic now that we've got that
back in windows input all we need to do
to access our window and by the way the
reason we need to access our window
maybe they started with that is because
we want to call GLW get cave okay that's
going to tell us whether or not a key is
actually down so the first thing that we
need to cast into here is actually
delighted to pass into here is our
window pointer and then it's the key
card so key card easy but window pointer
something that we need to actually pass
in that's what we're doing here we're
getting window which is going to be
equal to applications so we need to
include hazel slash application we're
doing application get and then get
window okay this gives us back just a
window reference once we have that
window reference we can get the jail FW
winter right by doing get native window
so this is going to be we just leave
this as order so this actually in this
case if we look at this it's a void
pointer that's fantastic but we actually
need to be a chill of w window pointer
right so we'll just start a cast it to
that
okay so static cast Jill have W window
and then that so now this of course is
the gel top your window pointer perfect
we can pass that in to window and there
we go
a function is fine okay so this of
course returns the state where it's kind
of pressed on art so we'll say Auto
state equals that and then here we just
need to return whether or not it's
pressed so return state equals jail
toffee press right or Philip W what is
it repeat right
like that oops I don't know how I've had
a static so there we go so now what
we're doing here is actually we're
asking GW if this key is pressed or
repeat or whatever if it's held down
basically then we'll return true
otherwise if it's you know the other
state which would be released then it's
gonna return false so there we go there
we have that pretty easy pretty simple
and now we have a way to also get the
native window which is really cool and
really powerful okay so if we go back to
input so hopefully this makes sense
right
we statically call input : : is key
pressed we put in our key code which
right now is the jelf w key code so
obviously we need to include shelf top
users which is a little bit unfortunate
but that's just the way it is for now
and then from here this calls the
implementation of it which is a virtual
function which in our case gets
dispatched into this windows window
sorry windows input class and calls this
function which of course actually us gel
W and that's how we get our keys so
hopefully all of that makes sense okay
cool so that is kind of how that works
now let's go back and actually we'll go
into input H and we'll do the rest of
this right so the other things that we
need to do for here is really just Mouse
stuff and that's probably all will do
for now so we'll have a static let's see
this can all all be in line by the way
because obviously it's implemented right
yeah but it'll be a static flirt for
example we'll get the outcomes in Mouse
position building mask upon the first is
mouse button pressed and then we'll do a
la each button that will return oops is
mouse button pressed button hopefully
you guys can see that but if not then
that's what it returns right and we'll
make that function in a minute and then
we'll do get Mouse X
yeah mouse why and and you can like keep
like filling this out obviously but for
now I think that's probably it
we don't know anything we need anything
else for now that's all I can think of
really oops
and we'll just actually do this and that
and that and these are flows okay so now
we have everything we obviously need to
implement this so back into windows
window sorry windows import we go I
always confuse the two
oops all right so we can take this away
and override I'll implement all of them
just using visual assist and then we can
just implement all of them really so
again with mouse button exactly the same
thing instead of Jeff whe we do gfw yeah
mouse button window and button now
there's no such thing as the repeats
type the mouse button or so it's just
going to be gelled up you press and then
for this that's as well paste is in
where we're actually going to use is
Jeff W get as a physician and then we
need window and then double X or Y pause
as output parameters all right um and
then we need to pass these in by their
memory address
so that's pointers and then we'll just
return in this case s mother's Creek you
could be like hey man that's look this
is a waste of time like then you know
this is you're doing both you're getting
both here whereas you're only returning
guest position and yeah I agree it's a
bit annoying we could return both
definitely as a tuple or as something
like that
in fact we might do that just now and
I'll show you guys kind of how that
works for fun so this is the same of Y
put Y position so we'll go back to input
and we'll do a quick little get Mouse
position I'll put it up here get Mouse
position just for turn 8s City pair of
floor and flow it get Mouse position and
cool let's copy this maybe I'm will just
do that okay and then we'll obviously
implement that in side windows input
just like that there's Mouse stuff I'll
create a function out of it and then
this will kind of do the same but
obviously over here it's just going to
return the pair so x position Y position
and the really cool thing about this by
the way is that obviously with kind of
simple cloth 17 if you're using c plus
17 which i think we are we can check
quickly whereas this language
yep civil has 17 what you can actually
do as I'll show you here really quickly
is if you get Mouse position like this
which we might actually end up doing
instead of doing all this you can
actually do something like this right
Auto XY equals get Mouse position and
then we can just return X like that okay
the reason this works is because you can
basically orderable you can basically
name these two floats that are being
returned which is really really cool and
it definitely makes tuples and pairs a
lot more convenient
because you basically can you know name
this whatever you want instead of
actually you know having to do pest City
yeah zero you know this is my variable
name feet like that to get like you know
cuz that that's what it would have been
like that's what you have to do in
signals 14 or below but it's tables in
C++ 17 you can just do this which is
really cool alright so that is that and
we don't have to cost or anything and
we'll do the same for here as well so
pretty cool stuff
glad we out of that that's basically it
right we've done absolutely everything
in our info class the other thing that
remains is actually creating this input
thing right so we need to actually
somewhere in our code we need to
actually create this instance and of
course since this actually has to be
Windows like the windows instance we
have to create it inside with a simple
well we don't have to but we're gonna do
it here so input as instance is going to
equal a null pointer in this case but
we're gonna just have it here and sorry
this is a input pointer so it equals
null pointer here and then we need to
initialize our input as some in some way
or another and that's what will actually
set this up so a good place to do this
would probably be Windows window and
then all we really need to do is
actually set it up here so this init
function would for example be a really
good place to do that
however again because input is
completely static it has no it's just
data right it's just data on a
collection of functions it does no
initialization it's not like it has a
constructor that relies on anything so
what we can actually do here is just set
it equal to new windows input right here
in that static block and that's it right
now we have this whole windows input
thing which actually will statically
initialize this so if we want to see
this in our code maybe an application
dot H or sorry applicational CPP all we
need to do to actually use this is I
will include
inputs dot H and then over here maybe in
the run loop or something like that I'm
just going to do a check or trace we'll
put this little thing in maybe we'll
just do a zero zero one and then we'll
put in I'll do order X Y as I did before
input yet Mouse position X Y okay let's
run this see what happens okay so we
should see over here that you can see we
have hazel and then the mouse position
right it's also printing all the events
that's a bit hard to see but there you
have hazel and in the mouse position
okay there your being printed so we can
definitely see that that is in fact
working anyway hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did you can hit that
like button huge thank you to all the
patrons on paper and upon 4/2 chatter
that helped make this video possible it
wouldn't be here without you if you want
to support that you guys get the next
video early so like you'll get it
straight away basically it's music this
public on youtube as well as the hazel
development branch where I've already
done all this stuff and way way way more
so in kind of skip ahead and see hazel
as it's actually being developed by me
my spare time next time we'll probably
implement those key codes and mouse
button coins that I talked about um feel
free to play around with this
I own the tests of get math position but
you guys should test get Mouse XY mouse
buttons and key buttons as well and make
sure all that's working so that's a
little bit of homework for you guys if
not if something if I did something
wrong
open upload a place on github last video
will teach you how to do that and then
we got home agitator and I'll fix it I
hope you guys into this video I'll see
you next time good bye
[Music]